urlaub
wo warst du im urlaub
ich war
ja
ich war an
was hast du dort gemacht
was hast du dort gemacht ich bin auf den
wellen gesurft
ich bin auf den wellen gesurft
oh du kannst surfen
[Musik]
du kannst surfen
ja sehr gut ja sehr gut
warst du auch im urlaub
ich war nicht im urlaub weil ich sparen
muss
letztes jahr eine weltreise gemacht
viele länder und städte kennen gelernt
ich habe viele länder und städte kennen
gelernt
ich bin mit dem flugzeug geflogen
ich habe viele sehenswürdigkeiten
besucht
ich war am strand
ich habe in hotels übernachtet
ich bin in den
ändert
ich bin in den bergen
es war toll
welche
das hat dir am besten gefallen
hat dir am besten gefallen mir hat
london am besten gefallen
mir hat london am besten gefallen
london ist eine internationale stadt
man kann dort gut essen
es gibt viel zu sehen
in den pubs gibt es gutes bier
magst du sport
ja ich liebe sport
ich mache zwei mal pro woche yoga
ich wandere gerne in den bergen
und ich jogge gerne
und ich gucke gerne
machst du auch noch anderen sport als
surfen
noch anderen sport als surfen
ich tanze gern in der disco ich tanze
gern in der disco
ich schwimme
mäßig ich schwimme regelmäßig es ist
schon halb sechs es ist schon halb sechs
ich muss noch im supermarkt einkaufen
danach koche ich das abendessen danach
koche ich das abendessen freunde kommen
zu besuch
freunde kommen zu besuch
nach dem essen spielen wir karten nach
dem essen spielen wir karten
wir möchten bezahlen bitte
wir möchten bezahlen bitte bezahlen sie
getrennt oder zusammen
bezahlen sie getrennt oder zusammen
ich bezahle die rechnung bitte ich
bezahle die rechnung bitte
was hast du heute gemacht
ich bin um 7
uhr aufgestanden
ich bin um 7 uhr aufgestanden
zuerst habe ich einen kaffee getrunken
und ich habe die zeitung gelesen und ich
habe die zeitung gelesen
danach habe ich mich geduscht danach
habe ich mich geduscht
dann habe ich meine zähne geputzt
dann habe ich meine zähne geputzt hast
du nichts gefrühstückt
hast du nichts gefrühstückt
doch natürlich
das frühstück ist die wichtigste
mahlzeit des tages
doch natürlich
das frühstück ist die wichtigste
mahlzeit des tages
ich habe
und ein stück toast gegessen ich habe
ein rührei und ein stück toast gegessen
um 9 uhr bin ich zur bushaltestelle
gegangen um 9 uhr bin ich zur
bushaltestelle gegangen
[Musik]
an der bushaltestelle habe ich auf den
bus gewartet
an der
stelle habe ich auf den bus gewartet ich
habe
ein paket auf die post gebracht
ich habe
danach habe ich meine freunde im
restaurant getroffen
wir haben
zusammen zu mittag gegessen
wir haben zusammen zu mittag gegessen
nach dem mittagessen bin ich zum
baumarkt gefahren
ich habe holzbretter
oft
ich habe holzbretter gekauft
dann habe ich in der garage und wirren
daten tisch repariert
dann habe ich in der garage unseren
gartentisch repariert
was hast du gemacht hast du gemacht
habe ausgeschlafen
ich habe ausgeschlafen
der hund hat mich um 10 uhr geweckt
ich bin mit ihm im park spaziert
unsere tochter hat mich angerufen
dann hat sie unsere enkelkinder gebracht
am nachmittag habe ich auf sie
aufgepasst
nachmittag habe ich auf sie aufgepasst
wir haben zusammen gespielt
dann habe ich im supermarkt die
lebensmittel eingekauft
danach habe ich das abendessen gekocht
bevor du nach hause gekommen bist habe
ich noch fern gesehen
ich noch gern gesehen
ich habe auf movie flix eine neue serie
begonnen
hast du gestern sport gemacht
ich bin durch den wald gelaufen ich bin
durch den wald gelaufen ich bin am
strand gelaufen ich bin am strand
gelaufen
ich habe yoga gemacht
ich bin fahrrad gefahren
ich habe
im fitnesscenter trainiert ich habe im
fitnesscenter trainiert
ich bin im hallenbad geschwommen
ich bin im see
an
ich bin im see geschwommen
ich bin auf dem pferd geritten
ich habe fußball gespielt
ich habe geschärft
ich habe geboxt
ich habe
geboxt
ich bin drachen geflogen
ich bin auf den berg geklettert
ich bin ski gefahren
ich bin seil gesprungen
ich habe ein bier getrunken
ich habe
ein bier getrunken
einen kaffee getrunken
ich habe
bild gemalt ich habe
ein bild gemalt
ich habe
ein buch gelesen
ich habe gemüse geerntet
[Musik]
ich habe pilze gesucht
ich habe geangelt
ich habe die blumen gegossen
ich habe
die blumen gegossen
ich habe die hecke geschnitten
tipp lernen werben immer mit einem
beispiel satz im präsens perfekt und
präteritum
lernen werben immer mit einem beispiel
satz im präsens perfekt und präteritum
er geht in die schule er geht in die
schule
er ist in die schule gegangen
er ging in die schule
habt ihr das video gefallen abonniere
unseren kanal hat dir das video gefallen
abonniere unseren kanal